what I want to do in this video is think
about the antiderivative of 1 over X or
another way of thinking about it another
way of writing is the antiderivative of
X to the negative 1 power and we already
know if we somehow try to apply that
anti power rule that inverse power rule
over here we would get something that's
not defined we would get X to the 0 over
0 doesn't make any sense and you might
have been saying ok well I know what to
do in this case when we first learned
about derivatives we know that the
derivative of medicine yellow the
derivative with respect to X of the
natural log of X is equal to 1 over X so
why can't we just say that the
antiderivative of this right over here
is equal to the natural log of X plus C
and this isn't necessarily wrong the
problem here is is it's not broad enough
and what when I say it's not broad
enough is that the domain over here for
our original function that we're taking
the antiderivative of is all real
numbers except for x equals 0 so over
here X cannot be equal to 0 while the
domain over here is only positive
numbers so over here X so in this for
this expression X has to be greater than
0 so it would be nice if we could come
up with an antiderivative that has the
same domain as the function that we're
taking the antiderivative of so if would
be nice if we could find an
antiderivative that is defined
everywhere that our original function is
so pretty much everywhere except for X
equaling 0 so how can we rearrange this
a little bit so that could be defined
for negative values as well well one one
possibility is to think about the
natural log of the absolute value of x
the natural log of the absolute value of
x so I'll put a little question mark
here because we don't really know what
the derivative of this thing is going to
be and I'm not going to rigorously prove
it here but I will give you kind of the
conceptual understanding so to
understand it let's plot let's plot the
natural log of x and I had done this
ahead of time so that right over there
is roughly what the graph of the natural
log of X looks like so what would the
natural log of the absolute value of x
is going to look like
well four positive X's four positive X's
it's going to look just like this
four positive X's you take the absolute
value of it is just the same thing as
taking that original value so it's going
to look just like that for positive X's
but now this is also going to be defined
for negative X's if you're taking the
the absolute value of negative one that
evaluates to just one so it's just the
natural log of one so you're going to be
right there as you get closer and closer
and closer to zero and from the negative
side you're going to take the absolute
value so it's essentially going to be
exactly this curve for natural log of X
but the left side of the natural log of
the absolute value of x is going to be
its mirror image if you were to reflect
around the y axis it's going to look
something like this
it's going to look something like this
so it's nice about this function as you
see it's defined everywhere it's defined
everywhere except for except for I'm
trying to draw it as symmetrically as
possible it's defined everywhere except
for x equals zero so if you combine this
pink part and and this part on the right
if you combine both of these you combine
both of these you get you get Y is equal
to the natural log of the absolute value
of x now let's think about its
derivative well we already know what the
derivative of the natural log of X is
and for positive values of x so let me
write this down for X is greater than
zero we get the natural log of the
absolute value of x is equal to the
natural log of X let me write this is
equal to the natural log of is equal to
the natural log of X and we would also
know since these two are equal for X is
greater than zero for X is greater than
zero the derivative the derivative of
the natural log of the absolute value of
x is going to be equal to the derivative
is going to be equal to the derivative
of the natural log of x the natural log
of x which is equal to which is equal to
1 over X for X greater than zero so
let's plot that let's plot that I'll do
that in green it's equal to 1 over X so
1 over X we've seen it before it looks
something like it looks something like
this
so let me my best attempt to draw it it
has both vertical and horizontal
asymptotes so it looks something like
this it looks something like this so
this right over here is 1 over X for X
is greater than 0 so this is 1 over X
when X is greater than 0 so all it's
saying here and you can see it pretty
clearly is the slope the slope right
over here the slope of the tangent line
is 1 and so you see that when you look
at the derivative the slope right over
here the derivative should be equal 1
here when you get close to 0 you have a
very very steep positive slope here and
so you see you have a very high value
for its derivative and then as you get
move away from 0 it's still steep it's
still steep but it becomes less and less
and less steep all the way until you get
to 1 and then and then it gets and then
it keeps getting less and less and less
steep but it never quite gets to an
absolutely flat slope and that's what
you see it's derivative doing now what
is the natural log of absolute value of
X doing right over here
when we are out here when we're out here
our slope is very close to 0 it's
symmetric the slope here is essentially
the negative of the slope here I could
do it may be clearer showing it right
over here whatever the slope is right
over here
whatever the slope is right over there
it's the exact negative of whatever the
slope is at a symmetric point on the
other side so if on the other side the
slope is right over here
over here it's going to be the negative
of that so it's going to be right it's
going to be right over there and then
the slope just gets more and more and
more negative right over here the slope
over here the slope is a positive 1 over
here it's going to be a negative 1 so
right over here our slope is a negative
1 and then as we get closer and closer
to 0 is just going to get more and more
and more negative so the derivative of
the natural log of the absolute value of
X for X is less than 0 looks something
like this looks like this and you see
you see and once again it's not a ultra
rigorous proof but what you see is is
that the derivative of the natural log
of the absolute value of x is equal to 1
over X for all X's not equaling 0 so
what you're seeing in or hopefully
you can visualize that the derivative
let me write it this way the derivative
the derivative of the natural log of the
absolute value of X is indeed equal to 1
over X for for all for all X does not
equal 0 so this is a much more
satisfying antiderivative for 1 over X
it has the exact same has the exact same
domain so when we think about what the
antiderivative is for 1 over X and I
didn't do a kind of a rigorous proof
here I didn't use the definition of the
derivative and all of that but I kind of
gave you a visual understanding
hopefully of it we would say it's the
natural log of the absolute value of X
plus C and now we have an antiderivative
that has the same domain as the function
that we're taking the antiderivative of